you write that what unites America is a
Creed it's not anything else uh and I
thought that was fascinating and apt
when I was growing up I used to think
that what unify us is culture
um though uh you and I grew up at a time
when there was a bit more of an American
monoculture than there is now uh back in
the days when there were only three or
four TV networks and everyone went and
saw the same uh TV shows and movies uh
Etc how would you define this American
creed uh that that unites us yeah I mean
I think the the Creed is it contains
ideas that are totally familiar to
everybody ideas that are baked into our
founding and our foundational documents
uh ideas of Liberty
um equality Equal justice under law
ideas of government of by and for the
people these words that in many ways
have become sort of Oh eye rolly you
know it's much easier to be cynical
about these words or to be scared about
the ways in which people have hijacked
those words uh uh for malevolent ends
but part of what we've got to do as
Americans is to recognize that a the
kind of remarkable I would say actually
exceptional inheritance that these ideas
actually are and Our obligation to
sustain them and and to kind of sustain
a sense of meaning in them but B that
the way that we do that is not just to
say hey people gather around and you
need to believe a little bit more in
freedom justice and equality
the way to do it actually is to
recognize that these ideas from the
get-go were ideas that weren't I mean we
talk about you know truth being
self-evident in the Declaration of
Independence but these ideas of freedom
and equality for instance are not
themselves self-evident in their
consequences or self-executing they
require us to figure out what do we do
with freedom you know there is a group
right now as we speak that's holding the
house hostage called the freedom caucus
right what is the meaning of freedom
right
um and it requires us to recognize at
the most basic level that America is an
argument we are meant to argue
perpetually we are meant to contest the
meaning of freedom we are meant to
contest perpetually the tension between
freedom and equality that when you have
too much Freedom you are trampling on
people's equality when you have too much
emphasis on leveling and equality you
end up trampling people's freedom and
that those tensions the tensions that we
go that go all the way back if you're a
fan of Hamilton the musical they go all
the way back to those rap battles
between Jefferson and Hamilton about the
size and the role of government and
Central national government versus local
you know voice and control uh the the
fight between the pluribus part of our
national motto and the Unum part
diversity and unity these are arguments
we are meant perpetually to have and so
what it means to be an American is to be
perpetually arguing over what it means
to be an American and to be grappling
with the contents of this Creed it's not
like oh here's the Creed it has all the
answers for us it's here's the Creed it
has all the questions for us and our job
is to know enough about our history know
enough about how people before us have
argued the Creed know about the things
that people have fought for fought each
other for struggled for the ways in
which they have not given up and not
succumb to Mere cynicism you know if
people if if black people in the United
States in the 1920s 30s and 40s had just
said you know what enough it's been 70
years of Jim Crow I'm giving up on the
idea of freedom I'm just rolling my eyes
at equality that's never coming right
then then you and I would not be here
right now having this conversation but
because a critical mass of people said
you know what but I continue I insist on
the meaning of these ideas even though
they've been betrayed from the get-go
and betrayed over and over again and
even though I today Labor under a system
designed to betray those ideals I still
insist that they mean something and I'm
going to organize by five by ten by a
hundred by a thousand uh people to come
together and shift the Norms that shift
the culture that finally will shift the
law in that case around segregation
civil rights but I think all of that
means what you know the Creed is is an
invitation to us to Grapple with its
meaning and then to ask what are we
going to do with it what are we going to
do about it and that to me
um again like yes that will eventually
get you to politics elections running
for office like you dude serving in
government like I did but long before
you get to that kind of stuff it's about
really spending some time and thinking
about what Have We inherited here and
what do we owe to this system and to
each other uh to kind of gain some
some Mastery of what it means to Grapple
with the American creed
[Music]